Here.
Thirty five years. We moved here in ninety
one before that we had lived very
briefly in color.
When we first got married we were there couple for about a
year and a half before we started looking for a house of mystery
and I'm married and
I know I grew
up in the Bronx thankfully and near Van
Cortlandt Park. So I've always kind of lived near parks.
Well life. Originally never been called a park then when I
lived in Manhattan for two or three years I lived near
Central Park Police. The dad. And if I
got married a party was too small to preclude me from place A
little bigger and. That was
affordable. And after the your there.
He started looking for us. And first came
to Park Slope Well we were kind of in the middle of actually negotiating on our House
and Capitol
Hill and came to one of the
concerts then shelled our Prospect Park
and. Andy mediately fell in love with the neighbors and.
I told Mike you have to take a look
at.
Well the picture was very beautiful
the park itself was a huge attraction
for the kind of activities everybody was.
Concerts and other activities. I think the first time I got my wife to
come was to the house tour that was being run by
the parks and civic Council all the time. And really enjoyed that a
lot. And you could see there were a lot more neighborhood
organizations than we were used to seeing in the the Manhattan or the part of Brooklyn
that we
were. At first living in this place and that was another to get
traction and. While we were still in the process of
buying the house that we eventually will which is on sixteenth
Street
between the eighth Avenue in Prospect Park West.
We where we are to never found out about this
organization called rogue stuff.
It's called. Revitalization of the southern area of the
slip and.
We joined that actually before we even finished firing.
Because we were interested in finding out more about the
neighborhood. You'll
say well they were. They were originally formed.
The original name was revitalization of
the son of seventh Avenue
South and the original idea
was to there were a lot of vacant stores south of ninth Street
at the chili. There's actually a big division in the neighborhood between.
The more developed parts of the Park Slope in the north
and in the central part would be
even the original housing stock was a little more serious.
But the whole part of Park Slope had actually
gone downhill by in the. Sixty's and early
seventy's and during the brownstone
revival
movement there was already a lot of fixing up of houses in the
north than Central Park
where this is some of the houses seem to be
more interesting introduce the details in the
architecture but there were plenty of good houses in the southern part of the slope it just had been a
little bit more of a working class neighborhood
originally. But when we started being
interested in moving to the
slope the really what we could afford the real estate agents told us to look in
the water look in
the south.
And I think there was even the store or my wife doesn't remember it twice to
be remember that it was either a store or restaurant
around ninth Street. That was called South of the border
because there was such a marked distinction at that
time and over the years I think
that distinction is kind of governor raced and.
You know our There was
a real sense of there was a the Park Slope
City Council had been active for. Probably over a hundred
years in
Brooklyn and they were much more concerned
with that central and northern area of the
sloop discussed kind of where they were located and roast us.
Was probably formed partly because they felt that the other part of the slope was
being
neglected and there were more vacant storefronts towards the
south.
Well originally they were just trying to promote.
More development in the
area more development of the store fronts never. It wasn't just a promoter.
More of a sense of community and to focus on community problems. But
eventually by the.
One. Now it's starting in one thousand eighty three they formed the idea
of forming an elegy
seeds and getting together a project to
actually provide along
with the shopping strip along Seventh Avenue.
And from eighty three to eighty six. You know.
They were working to get funds from the city and state which we eventually got.
And those funds were used to provide matching funds
for people who wanted to upgrade their
strong front foot in
security and also providing funds for putting in tree planting
trees and garbage receptacles to.
One of the things that they did was booklet of guidelines
for storefront
relevation which had the intention
that to prevent like really Gary
shorefront from being created along to create a more
uniform sort of feel on the
street
you know as suggested guidelines it was a new news. No way to require anything but I think a
lot
of merchants were very receptive to that idea of making it a
more attractive strip along that
area.
Uses. How did the problem was we were very successful during the run
of the project
which but then around eighty seven. City.
Back on funds for the seasons area
and I think there was kind of a political thing going on too between the city
council and the borough
president the borough president said had their own
funding discretionary funding cut by the mayor's
office relation and
the City Council is trying to get people to work through them rather than through
the borough presidents
and and when they did do that for a president
golden apparently was not too happy with that and the Enter just cutting
off funds pretty some similarity to the number of the L D C's a
ten point.
So our project. The rule. We had had a project director we
actually had a store front
lines seventh Avenue which we
had
gotten very cheaply from but we
had we had to fix it up ourselves and sweat equity solicits.
And we had a project director who is very good excellent
and really marvelous things we helped form of
Merchants Association. Along slowly in the stricter.
And they did promotion shopping promotions need.
And the idea really what is that playing making us strong for the
spine long seventh avenue that would also help development
or the rest of the
neighborhood. So after that brand we started to
do get more involved in other smaller
projects. We had a
newsletter that. Provided information
on various aspects of which
and researching your building history kitchen.
So there wasn't a
very widely distribute was distributed mostly within the membership because we really
didn't have a lot of funds to do. But we started
having fundraisers which you're the first couple were.
Around Christmas time a holiday arts and music festival in the
armory
use method we used to have most of
our meetings in the officers' club of the
armory. And chill
of the armory passed away from National
Guard control and then the city had taken over for a while and
then eventually it was turned over
to there's a lot of controversy over the army over the
years both because of the homeless shelter there and because
of what was what we're going to be the plans for after the
city bowed out of running
it and
where it ended up being eventually being.
Managed well actually has two things going on it is still a homeless shelter
there and we were very influential in keeping.
The population there kept it for a long time. Was kept at
seventy when there.
There was an attempt at one point to turn it into an
assessment center which would have had of people just coming
transiently for short periods in another. And we were able to keep it as
a kind of more not permanent home
but more of a long term thing where people could actually feel
like they're part of the community
it's There was a lot of controversy over the shelter there
because there were some groups
that were adamantly opposed to having anybody there and all
that raised a lot of Cannick of. I mean a lot of
crime and is easy courses.
And they were to the shelter
and most of the residents were not thrilled at having the shelter there
but. We were trying to make it something manageable.
That wasn't threatening.
Eventually the city finally turned the management of
or the shelter over to a nonprofit camp.
And I would say that they don't excellent job of managing
and.
I think I think things are pretty
solidly down about. I don't think their people get too upset
if you suddenly heard that there were plans to expand it. I'm sure
you get people getting mad again each.
Well
we have most of the time there
was. Either co-presidents or president and vice president.
Mike Rice was the longest
serving president of recess.
I think he had about
seven dreams.
And his ear.
And there were we were not founding members of it.
I think probably the two most influential people in the Row
Source were a couple called Carlin you see Judy Carson
in this they were there from the
start calling the architect
and
he also was involved with the park for the civic unfolds and he was
kind of our liaison with the Civic Council as well is doing
various roles through
such and his wife was this second. Longest
serving
president and she was probably the one that to the most
work in getting the fundraising committees to gather and
printing
our annual fundraisers and stuff like that.
Well
why funfest doesn't alas up
until
like something new that but it was kind of on a whole
different people and unity was. Well the.
The founding father of our arrest was some finding Peter
Altshuler
but. He moved out of the neighborhood after a couple of
years so I don't think he was aside from that year that was found
in seventy eight he was in the leadership position after
the break.
Well I don't I'm not sure exactly when he left the neighborhood. I didn't
really know him but I think he was gone by the time writing terms. But
then the duty was president eighty one.
See. He says and.
He's sixty seven she's sick of it would
be kind of hard to know my wife was president of the
line to move forward
and
well almost the last five years and then our neighbor Barbara Baron
had been co-president with her for a couple
of years and I think she was the president had
the final year before we merged with the Civic Council in two thousand and one.
Oh
yes we had a lot of community meetings on little sorts of
different issues in the neighborhood from
drugs and crime to transit to
we we also had events
like. The Droid centennial of the Brooklyn Bridge.
We
had we had talks on history the
area had a nice talk at
the Prospect Park picnic us about
the one that was done for the environmental center. We had
a talk on the Battle of Brooklyn boy somebody had written
a book about.
Call
cards women would periodically give talks either on the history
or the architecture of the flu.
I think I was interested in a very
definitely not as knowledgeable about as some
people.
We were also influential in getting the house tour extended
to something there. The slew of. First time
was
seventeen rating. That they did.
Very rooted in there. I think I feel more room to huge here the well definitely where
we didn't know when
had I was fairly we need in my neighborhood when
I was growing up as a kid but de Botton is aware of any
neighborhood organization. They're cheering when I was in the
Bronx.
Well
both are pretty liberal communities the area that I grew up in the
Bronx had a stronger
relationship with some of the Union early
unions for the co-op thing in the neighborhood all our
lives right now my father was a doctor and he was kind of
the treated kind of like the community
doctor
and pregnancy that I had a much stronger feeling
about community organizations. And involved when
they came through and also it's a very diverse neighborhood and.
When we moved into
our house our most of our neighbors were probably Irish American.
But there were some a lot of news in the neighborhood very very big.
Gain lesbian community. And I think it's a very
tolerant neighborhood and she's something I enjoy and it's.
Not willingly I can really can't imagine someplace all
cyclists comfortable to fans of New York Jets old.
Gibson
looking to coherent chronologically
here.
Well.
There's always a lot of complaints about gentrification sneers than.
It is an issue you. You do worry about where
people who'll have to leave because of hard. Rents are going to end
up but I guess for for me it's worked out for a nicely.
When we happen to live here at the time we thought the prices were very high
but knowledge
skyrocketed. But you're sometimes worried is it going to become
a neighborhood just of rich people are going to lose the diversity of.
Well things I find very encouraging is to see more
and more young people move into the
neighborhood the same time fairly diverse backgrounds and.
So I guess there's still a lot of hope for the area.
And I haven't seen any decline in the neighborhood since I've lived here it's all
been pretty much on an upward trajectory.
So I have a lot of optimism. Thank you.